Українські позиції в селищі Опитне під Бахмутом
обороняють бійці чеченського батальйону імені Джохара Дудаєва.
Нині ЗСУ відступили від селища, бої тривають у самому Бахмуті.
Разом з українцями місто теж обороняють чеченці, або як вони себе називають - нохчі.
Ці хлопці нещодавно повернулися з Донбасу, аби за кілька днів знову поїхати туди для виконання бойових завдань.
Боєць із позивним "Мага" воює у складі батальйону Дудаєва.
Він був ще дитиною, коли розпочалася перша чеченська війна,
але в Бахмуті побачив багато схожого з подіями на батьківщині.
Всюди у Росії один і той самий почерк.
Треба було знищувати спершу всі укріплення, усі будівлі, а потім уже йти піхотою.
Це точно так само, як і в Чечні.
Іде перша хвиля піхоти, вона гине, друга, третя.
І коли доходить до сьомої-восьмої, вони забирають якісь позиції. І так вони йдуть далі.
М'яса в них повно, так що… Раби звикли так жити.
"Мага" жив у Європі, але приїхав в Україну в 2016 році.
На питання, що його мотивує воювати на українському боці, відповідає не вагаючись.
Слова Джохара Дудаєва, який сказав, що коли зійде українське сонце, Росії більше не буде.
І ми намагаємося підняти сонечко.
У складі Інтернаціонального легіону ЗСУ нині воюють п'ять чеченських добровольчих підрозділів.
Один із них - батальйон імені Шейха Мансура.
Він з'явився у 2014 році. Бійці підрозділу теж нині захищають Бахмут.
Батальйону імені Джохара Дудаєва теж уже дев'ятий рік.
Після повномасштабного вторгнення його бійці звільняли Київщину,
першими заходили до деокупованої Балаклії на Харківщині.
У батальйоні Дудаєва кажуть, що всі чеченські підрозділи співпрацюють між собою.
У їхніх лавах є навіть українці.
Вони воюють проти нашого спільного ворога.
І у нас в основному йдуть такі мотивовані хлопці - з Європи, з Чечні.
Є хлопці з Грузії, дуже багато.
Ось ми збираємося і додатково в нас нині йде набір.
Охочі стати до лав батальйону Дудаєва проходять відбір,
потім - двомісячне навчання.
Значну увагу приділяють фізичній формі й витривалості.
Також у бійців регулярно проходять тренування з бойової підготовки.
Батальйон не отримує забезпечення від української держави.
Утім під час виконання завдань бійці діють спільно з українськими підрозділами
й отримують від них усе необхідне.
А також здобувають трофейну зброю: як ось цю станину до кулемета.
Чеченські бійці батальйону не розголошують свого громадянства.
Хоча більшість із них давно живуть в Україні.
Бійці бачать багато спільного між чеченцями й українцями.
Проблема в тому, що росіяни ніколи не сприймали українців як рівних собі,
і ніколи нікого не сприймали як рівних.
Ми завжди були якимись окремими.
Так, ми тут іноді стикаємося із, скажімо так, залишковими проявами "русского мира",
коли деякі українці нас сприймають через призму тієї пропаганди,
яка лилася проти нас довгі роки.
І коли вони кажуть "я думав, ви такі", я таким людям кажу: "Ти не думав, тобі сказали".
Тобі сказало російське телебачення, тобі показали ці дурні фільми російські,
де десятеро російських солдатів обороняються від трьох тисяч чеченських бойовиків.
Водночас бійці згадують українських добровольців,
які поїхали воювати в Чечню в 90-х.
Кажуть, що приклад українців мотивує їх і нині.
Крім того, чеченці згадують спільну історію.
Ще з часів Голодомору, коли в Чечні приймали українських дітей,
коли приходили голодні люди, вони проходили через Кавказ.
Тоді чеченці збирали цих дітей, навчали їх чеченській мові, щоб НКВД-исти не могли їх розрізнити.
Науковець Марат Ільясов, який виїхав з Чечні після першої чеченської війни й нині працює у США,
теж проводить між українським і чеченським народами історичні паралелі.
Ми з одного пострадянського минулого і це вже нас об’єднує.
Ми страждаємо від цього приблизно однаково.
Українці пережили геноцидний голод.
Більшість чеченців пережили геноцидну депортацію.
І все це була справа рук Радянському Союзу.
А до того обидва народи постраждали від Російської імперії, що виглядало приблизно так само.
Марат Ільясов - член чеченської діаспори, яка налічує до півмільйона людей по всьому світу.
Більшість із них виїхали з Чечні після приходу до влади Рамзана Кадирова.
За словами науковця, нині у діаспори немає єдиного лідера.
Але є негативне ставлення до Росії і підтримка України.
Ільясов сумнівається, що в окупованій Росією Чечні можливе повстання,
але майбутнє його країни, як і історія, тісно переплетені з Україною.
У разі перемоги України, у що я щиро вірю, думаю, логічно буде, що Путіна усунуть від влади.
Як наслідок його усунення, Кадиров втратить підтримку і захист Кремля.
А це відкриє можливості для людей, які нині в Європі, не лише військових,
але й політиків, учених, підприємців, інтелігенції, для досить потужної чеченської діаспори
повернутися в Чечню, якщо вони захочуть.
А це буде великим кроком до здобуття Чечнею незалежності.
Про незалежність для своєї держави мріють і бійці, які воюють в Україні.
Я думаю, ми доб'ємося свободи.
Уже 400 років у нас триває боротьба за свободу.
Покоління за поколінням. Іншалла, на моєму поколінні це зупиниться.
Я мрію дожити до того дня, коли я в Україні не почую російську мову:
якщо ти говориш російською, щоб тебе не розуміли.
Як не розуміють російську мову чехи, поляки.
Українську розуміють, а російську ні.
Тому що це імперська мова, штучна мова, як і країна штучна.
І ця війна не скінчиться і не буде ніякого мирного життя, поки Росія буде існувати як Росія.
Російська республіка на споконвічно російських територіях -
будь ласка, живіть і нікому не заважайте.
Для командира батальйону Дудаєва - це вже третя війна з Росією.
Він пройшов обидві чеченські. І каже, що про втому від війни нині не може бути мови.
Ми вже 30 років у війні. Бути вільним - це не просто так.
У рабстві якщо люди хочуть жити, це вже інше питання.
А ось за свободу треба боротися, працювати треба, і життя треба віддавати.